there something that you don't like
about being a youtuber or oh wow
like there's gonna be something that's
like you know grind your gears isn't
that oh
sure sure absolutely well gosh i mean
ah let's see sorry the list is just
winning
i
i feel like most of the issues that i
have always end up being with myself for
whatever reason like i could do this
better
that's not the answer i know it's not i
know it's not i'm thinking i'm not
perfect enough
i know i'm thinking that's that's like
the job into the answer you give
whenever whenever like
oh gosh no one when you're in a job
interview and someone asks you what are
your flaws i'm like i work too hard
i'm just such a hard worker and i'm a
perfectionist
i never sleep yeah exactly well let's
see um
if i'm if i'm to be honest uh let's see
i mean obviously sometimes you know
chad and you know they're a lot they
mean well and i love my chest
people are [ __ ] yeah exactly
and you know people people tricking me
into saying things
i don't like it all right listen uh
listen i understand that you support me
go [ __ ] yourself please don't please
stop me can you stop it
can you can you just can you stop there
right you're telling someone to go [ __ ]
themselves right
yeah i mean i'm trying so hard to be
entertaining and and for all of us to
have fun together right
and you're just you're just trying to
[ __ ] on my day and everyone's day
it's rude yeah you tell them you tell
him you tell him man
you're one hour of reviews you dropped
this queen started going off
going off gotta get the gotta get the
angry face going right this is my sad
face it looks like i'm in pain i'm sorry
excuse me
sorry here we know now i'm blushing hang
on just a moment i have to adjust myself
okay yeah [ __ ] you
[Laughter]
i'd raise my knuckle you be if i could
but i can't right now oh
i didn't i'm happy we've got that moment
yeah yeah that's gonna be there's
nothing changing
[Music]
there's also some other stuff that
pisses me off in terms of like technical
difficulties and whatnot because
i was under the impression that i was
doing a pretty decent job right
but you know in the beginning my pc
specs are fine
you know they're still pretty [ __ ] right
but eventually they got you know we got
better stuff
um and i just a lot of the there's a lot
of feedback about stuff that i can't
change and i know it's my job to take it
and do what i can with it and we did
that but it gets to a point where just
kind of [ __ ] up again
yeah oh my god